how can a writer take an ordinary idea
and transform it into what you call
heightened concept by doing what
Shakespeare did so let's think about
Shakespeare for a moment Shakespeare
started the Globe Theater and it was in
a very dangerous unincorporated part of
London because it was illegal in London
to have a theater because you didn't the
the the royalty did not want common
people hearing ideas CU that could
dangerous it was illegal they would have
been killed so they did it in a place
that was unregulated not part of London
it was in a place where it was uh
brothel and uh gambling and and people
were were murdered and the people who
are watching Shakespearean plays had
never seen theater before because it
used to only be royalty so their
standing is is basically unless they
have any money they pay you know a
shilling or a pence and they're standing
in this huge pit
which is disgusting because there's no
bathroom so let's you know and it's the
M of Bubonic plague so this is this is
pretty disgusting and this is what's
really interesting when we see a play we
know about the predal arc we know that
there's a stage and when the lights go
up there's going to be actors talking we
don't talk to them we listen they
pretend they don't see us we don't
interact with them and we listen to the
play no one who saw a Shakespearean play
knew any of that they had never seen a
play how do you know that mean they
don't know that so they're talking and
drinking and whatever they're doing and
then these people get on stage and start
talking well what's to stop them from
talking back what's to stop them from
getting on stage and interacting with
them there's only one thing that can
stop them which is the rest of the
audience the rest of the audience has to
be like hey mate shut up I want to hear
this so Shakespeare knew he had to grab
people's attention right away or and I'm
not
kidding his actors were going to be
maybe murdered and that's not a joke
these were rough drunk people who knows
what would happen so he has to get
people's attention like that or this is
very dangerous by the way if you want to
succeed as a writer you got to get the
reader attention like that because as I
have said before Studio readers uh we
are taught to read the first scene or
two and stop and if we don't have to
keep reading we don't so you have
Shakespeare's problem now
Shakespeare here's what he
did he actually let me tell you what he
didn't do he didn't do high concept
because High concept is just bigger like
I'll do a story with these people and
there's a meteor coming down or there's
a murder and because here's the thing
people who are watching that can't
relate to that and why would they care
there's a meteor coming like so what
like that has no connection to them
that's the problem with high concept
nobody
cares people have to make an emotional
connection to want to read the next page
or watch but this is a problem what if
Shakespeare put characters on stage that
the audience could relate to for
instance a male character who has an
overbearing father and no matter what
the character does the father's never
happy and this poor guy is tortured and
he can never make his dad
happy well you know what a lot of the
people in the audience could relate to
that and you have another character they
relate to and what would happen your
actors would be killed because why would
they stand in the
filth watching what they could watch in
real life why would they watch something
that they can just see all around them
in their life that's not interesting so
we've got a conundrum
if we have something heightened Larger
than Life which is what a lot of people
like to talk about nobody cares if you
use real life people emotionally connect
but why pay for this why stand all right
so Shakespeare invented a technique that
is used today by all successful show
Runners and feature film writers he
didn't go heighten concept he didn't go
bigger but he did did is he said the
only way I can hold their
attention is by
telling extraordinary stories
extraordinary everyone wants to be
extraordinary well just think of the
word
extraordinary you just divide it
extraordinary extraordinary so what's
ordinary it's something that everybody
can relate to what is extra it is
heightened version of ordinary
it is a heightened
version so for
instance have
I ever been so freaked out about money
so scared that I can't
survive that I have been tempted to do
something that's not exactly right yes
have I ever done something that I felt
wasn't exactly right yeah a few times
now I have Shame about that did I ever
cook crystal meth and sell crystal meth
no and I would never do that but when I
watch Breaking Bad I have a guy who's
just at the end of his rope and he's
economically devastated it's not fair
and his family's going to be devastated
and he's gonna and I can I can relate to
that that is ordinary but this is
heightened because he's going to die and
his family destitute and he's going to C
Crystal MTH so when I watch that show
I'm like that's me but that's not me
like I can relate to Walter White and go
yeah I get that but I would never do
that that's what makes the show so
magical
because if I watch that I go oh my God
that's me that's what I do then that's
painful that's not or or the office uh
either one but I'm just going to go with
the ruas version so you got this
character and he really cares what
everyone thinks about him and when
people are talking to he's always like
trying to pass himself off as an expert
and he goes too far he exaggerates too
much and he just tries to sound like
everyone loves him he's the greatest
boss but you realize he's just a sad
little man he's like the wizard in The
Wizard of Oz behind his little curtain
okay can I relate to that yes do I care
what people think about me yes do I
sometimes
exaggerate
yes um is it sometimes me a little
pathetic probably my wife would say
sometimes
um am I delusional that I walk around
claiming to do things I haven't done and
just brag about things that have no
reality no so when I watch the office
I'm like oh my God that's me but that's
not me that's why it's fun and I can
laugh because I can identify with the
pain but I could be like but that's not
me I'm not nearly as pathetic as that
guy so it's ordinary but it's an
extraversion flea bag I
mean
she the way she escapes pain is through
inappropriate well sex lots of sex
that's her pain avoidance and her mom
died and it caused her so much
pain that she sleeps with her best
friend's boyfriend best friend finds out
and ends up dying as a result and flea
bag now because she had pain and she
couldn't deal with her mom's death the
way she dealt with it was so
inappropriate she now feels
responsible I think justifiably for her
best friend's death she obviously didn't
try to kill her best friend but it was a
result and now in the first season and
in the second season she's just trying
to have more and more sex to try to
disassociate and deal with that pain
okay have I had great pain in my life
yes have
I done coping mechanisms yes is it sex
not for me sex was never my thing I mean
it was never my uh coping mechanism but
other things were we don't need to go
into that but other things like being a
workaholic that's one thing um and has
when I've had pain and I've done coping
mechanisms has that negatively impacted
people I care about absolutely you know
back when I was a writer I was a lot of
pain I would I would just be such a
workaholic I wasn't around my wife and I
wasn't really present always in the
relationship and that's certainly
damaging to her so I watch flea bag and
I'm like oh I can relate to that but I'm
not her I didn't kill anyone I didn't do
anything that
egregious um so it makes it safe and
comfortable to watch it it's like okay
okay that's that's an exaggerated
version of me so Shakespeare with Hamlet
here's a guy whose father is overbearing
and Hamlet can't measure up and the
people in the audience can relate to
that but right out of the
gate we learn now people in the audience
were like yeah my family's really messed
up and all this stuff is but here's
what's not happening my uncle did not
have sex with my mom and then kill my
father to be with his wife and then my
father comes to me as a ghost and says
You must finally be a man and go kill
him like okay my life's messed up and
crazy but it's not that bad that's an
extraordinary opening to one of of the
most timeless and successful stories
ever
because it is an ordinary emotional
experience that is made extra that is
heightened same thing with the Wizard of
Oz Dorothy loves her dog more than
anything and she's running from the
witch because the witch is going to kill
her in Toto and the only way she can get
what she wants is she has to go at the
witch she has to attack the witch with
no plan of how to defeat the witch well
we all have to do that in life I mean
this is film courage so let's talk about
courage I mean we all have our demons we
all have our
witches and we all want things we want
to be successful as writers or
successful this where be successful
husbands and wives or
parents we want to be successful but we
want to keep running from the things
that scare us the most and guess what
the only way to really be
successful to stop
running away from what scares us and run
at what scares us and that's the only
place that is that's the courage you
want to talk about courage there's your
courage well I can relate to that and I
usually run away sometimes I've run
out I didn't have flying monkeys I
didn't have a witch I mean that
especially as a kid even now this the
flying monkeyy is terrifying me so I
watch when we watch it we can relate to
it but it's heightened that's what I
mean it's a heightened concept and
that's what Shakespeare did with all of
his plays and he had to and it's the
same technique that the con Brothers use
the writers of the
baru Phoebe Waller Bridge Tina Fay
Milligan jeni con and when you learn to
do it then we can add
hopefully
the characters and the stories that are
in you we can add that an impact on the
world but the question is film courage
do you have the courage do you have the
courage to go there do you have the
courage to do
that